six five zero area code let's go to our
caller from six five zero
who's this where you calling from hi
David this is Adam from San Francisco
go ahead Adam so I think the upcoming
elections are definitely going to be a
litmus test of sports on whether the
country is gonna swing back from the
from one side of populism from the right
to left agree so my question to you is
is the country ready to swing to another
you know progressive or or another
populist ideology or from what Trump has
given us in the last two years or so
perhaps the countries like okay we've
tried and tested it let's swing back to
the center excellent question the
country has been ready for a long time
to make a big move to the left the
problem is number one a lot of those
people who already aren't voting okay so
voter turnout is embarrassingly low
two-thirds or more of Americans think
the government has a responsibility to
provide at least the basic level of
health care to everybody regardless of
ability to pay
where are those people on Election Day
they're not all voting right so I think
the answer is yes the country is more
than ready to go to the left
particularly after these two atrocious
years of Trump but most people don't
vote in midterms a lot of people aren't
politically engaged and our elected
officials don't reflect the positions of
their constituents and so will the
country actually make a big move to the
left in three and a half weeks on
election day I don't know but the
country is definitely more than ready
it's just people aren't going out and
actually making it happen got it thank
you all right no problem thank you for
the call appreciate it